or le cinéma toujours et l'ouverture du
festival de cannes c'est pour mercredi
le jury de ce 63e rendez-vous sera
présidé par tim burton un réalisateur
créatif fantaisiste son portrait ce soir
avec pascal deschamps et mathias barrois
il fait tourner des stars tim burton en
est lui aussi c'est devenu le veut et si
son dernier film alice triomphe sous les
écrans du monde entier
c'est parce que son cinéma fait rêver
cinéma qu'on aime parce que ce cinéma
les gestes une libellule tim burton donc
les là va marcher sur ses petites pattes
il est toujours prêt à s'envoler vers
toutes les aventures il était une fois
un petit garçon prénommé timothée qui
vous êtes une tendresse particulière aux
monstres devenus grands tim burton eu de
cesse de donner vie dans ses films aux
étranges créatures de ses rêves et ses
rêves en était plein petit garçon
solitaire il dessine plus tard il se
réfugie dans les films d'horreur
l'un de ses premiers courts métrages est
un hommage un acteur de série b d'une
grande gentillesse mais tu veux faire
des films d'horreur comme vincent brasse
tous les enfants savent dessiner tous
les enfants ont de l'imagination
mais quand ils deviennent adultes
souvent où ils la perdent
moi j'essaie de m'accrocher à cette part
d'enfance
une part d'enfance qui ne l'a toujours
pas quitté hollywood mettre un certain
temps reconnaître son talent a apprécié
sa singularité
mais grâce à quelques gros succès comme
charlie batman ou la planète des singes
il a toujours pu tourner des films plus
personnels qui ont fait de lui un auteur
respecter comme edward aux mains
d'argent ou l'étrange noël de monsieur
jack
étrange mais
encore
tim burton devrait avoir son parc
d'attraction entre johnny depp et tim
burton c'est une longue histoire
sept films en tout les ont réunis johnny
depp c'est son double de cinéma car
personne n'a su mieux que lui incarner
les doutes les espoirs les folies de tim
burton comme dans ed wood le portrait
d'un réalisateur de séries z passionnés
et incompris que tim burton a tiré de
l'oubli
à ce jour personne n'a encore vu ce long
métrage j'ai tenu à vous réserver
l'exclusivité de mon talent ses jantes
et c'est à peine élu il a été présenté
il ya dix sept ans et de plus dans la
france une classe à part dans le coeur
du réalisateur parce que dit il si on le
comprend en france même quand les gens
n'aimaient pas mon film il pouvait être
sensible à la poésie à des détails alors
qu'ailleurs les réactions étaient du
genre c'est super ou c'est nul ici c'est
un endroit par expert auprès chômé
tim burton incarne aujourd'hui l'audace
la poésie l'humour l'imagination la
sensibilité la tolérance son palmarès
devrait être à son image